Now the lowest common denominator might of been tricky here. You want to make
sure that it's n times 6 minus 3n. This is one factor in these denominators and
n is a completely different factor. So we want to multiply those two together to
get our LCD. For the first term we'll have 5 times 6 minus 3 n. And for the
second term we'll have plus 4 times n, or positive 4 n. The right side of our
equation is simply 2 n squared. Since these factors reduce to one. If we
distribute positive 5, and combine our like terms, we'll get 30 minus 11 n
equals 2 n squared. Now that we're at this part we have a quadratic equation,
since we have a 2 N squared. We want to set this equation equal to zero by
moving or rearranging these two terms. If we move these terms to the right side
of the equation we'll get zero is equal to 2 N squared, plus 11 minus 30. This
is something that we can factor and solve. So here is our equation and, to
factor it, we want to find the factors of negative 60 that's sum to positive 11.
When we use factoring by grouping, we'll get 2n plus 15 as 1 factor. And n minus
2 as another. Finally, we set each factor equal to zero, and then solve the 2
remaining equations. N could equal negative 15/2, or n could equal positive 2.
And here's where we want to be careful. We need to check for the excluded values
for the original equation. We know n cannot equal zero, since this denominator
would equal zero. And the fraction would be undefined. We also know that n
cannot equal 2. If n was equal to 2 both of these denominators would be zero and
these two fractions would be undefined. This means that this solution is not
valid. We can only take this as our actual solution. So here's our solution set,
negative 15 halves. Fantastic algebraic thinking for getting that one correct.